so let's not write down the information
that they provide for us X is a positive
number and they define theta now the
first thing I asked you to do is to
simplify this now if you have a look at
the rest of the question you can kind of
get some clues as to where this might go
okay but just on the face of it what
might be what might be your first
instinct I guess or how you could
simplify that expression any takers
what could you possibly do with it you
could expand it couldn't you we have
some identities for expanding these
kinds of things okay but there's an
issue with that idea let's just take
that idea and see where it goes I say
you know can a - what is the expansion
for today - the way I remember by the
way you have this one of those plus and
ones a - the way that I remember is I
think a double angle if this was you
know a plus a right you're gonna get
you're not gonna get zero on the top you
kind of ten a minus 10 a four double
hangar that doesn't make any sense
you've got to Tenace so that one must be
plus that's why this one's - anyway
whatever floats your boat
what's a little nail now that's the
expansion and that's fine but when you
look at the particular angles that we
have you ran into a problem don't you
because for instance if I say this is a
and this is B okay maybe right the first
part of this you write Ted PI on - wait
hold on a second
what's 10 pylon 2
it's under flying right cuz tan of
course it looks like this and there's
your pie on two right there yes
so trigger tensions would normally be a
good place to go when you see something
like this but in this case bit of a dud
okay what else could we do okay so I can
think in terms of other kinds of trig
functions right n itself is an identity
what's an identity for its sign-on cause
isn't it right so I could write this and
that would be true wouldn't it
okay has it made things any better it
has right where can I go from here I I
could expand but there's a quicker way
come on have a look so I'm planning to
you might have seen if that's an
identity of its of its own isn't it what
is it
that's cause this and that's that that's
how we define cause actually that's
close and conversely or the denominator
that's sign so this is good okay well I
could write this as cot okay but being
that I've got this expression right so
this is going to be in terms of turns if
I have a tan inverse and tan together
that's going to be an easier thing to
combine rather than cuts and turns so
I'm going to write this as one over and
yeah okay and I know we're you know what
sceneries okay so I'll write that in I
just don't really careful at this point
okay we have already noticed that when
you put trig functions and inverse trig
functions you get though you can't be
too willy nilly about it because they're
not exact inverses of each other they're
restricted right now I want you to
remember this we looked at this example
very briefly right what is the for what
values is this going to be just equal to
X hmm because we noticed you know for
instance if I did
sign of Samos okay this is equal to X
but only sometimes
do you remember what values of X it
works for is it negative plan to - phone
- all right is that ring a bell
okay so it's true sometimes not all the
time though okay now when you have a
look at this what's going to happen are
you gonna have a problem like this hmm
what is this come from Wade you tell me
this like why not three since not 2 pi
or not - 2 pi or not anything why is it
those values it's because this this
right this corresponds to that domain
within reach within which we received a
sign right and therefore it course
wanted to the range of this okay now
what do you think about this right
what's the domain of 10 inverse the
domain of tell you this what's it looks
like it just goes he just goes forever
okay so in fact this one is equal to 1
over X and it's equal to 1 over X all
the time that's kind of nice it's not
like this one or if I did it for cars as
well okay so I'm actually going to take
note of that I'm going to say as 10 of
10 inverse is equal to X I'll introduce
some notation here just so I can be a
bit shorter if you remember from
inequality inequalities whatever and I'm
psyched down Abe's they don't remember
what it means it means for all values of
x that of real okay what we're values in
X if you like now big oh that's good
that's on that's my expression on -
Peter I can bring it down to that and
that's as simple as it gets